Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr.
Did I say that too quickly?
Did I not wait till it turned on?
I don't fucking know.
All I know is I don't have time to do this shit today because I've got to run to
the airport.
So this is bill burr and this is time for the Thursday afternoon.
Monday morning plowed kits just before Friday.
And just checking,
just checking in on you.
Um,
my wife is still sleeping downstairs and um,
I don't even think I have time to do a half hour,
so I'll tell my guy to tack on a little more.
Mr Mullis to tack on,
uh,
you know enough time so it fucking works out.
All right.
I'm on my way out to a Philadelphia.
Um,
and uh,
I actually didn't know American Airlines flew director.
Now you know why?
Cause they bought fucking USA.
Eh,
it's like fucking nine airlines left.
That's like the race right now.
You know who's going to own everything.
Like all the airlines first are all the banks.
Either way,
you're not going to have any fucking options,
right?
It's going to be all American Airlines.
Is this is what the prices would you rather walk?
Yeah.
Won't shut your fucking mouth thing gets done.
It's a plane.
We'll put you down by say luggage.
Um,
so anyways,
um,
I actually got a few more suggestions about a cheese steaks when I go to,
Philly of course I don't have them in front of me because I just had to take my
fucking dog out.
He's been up all night.
She had the shits.
So,
uh,
I'll be looking at him up.
So I think I'm going to get to one in the afternoon,
one at night,
you know,
just gradually give back all the fucking weight that I took off.
I'm up to a buck 73,
uh,
brutal,
but,
um,
I just got to hang in there and maintain like once 71 to [inaudible] 73.
You know,
I worked out yesterday,
I just took my dog for a hike and it's going to maintain this shit and I just
got to make it to November 16th cause then I'm basically off for the rest of the
fucking year.
My years done,
it winds down and uh,
you know,
and I'll just work out like a madman and then it's great.
Last time I was like one 87 when I had to drop down.
Now I'm just one 73.
That's all right.
Right.
Ooh.
Um,
so anyways,
yeah,
my dog last night
fucking thing.
I don't know what happened.
It just was just,
I dunno,
it's starting to get old man.
It's kind of freaking me out man.
It's kind of having like if I don't take it out enough,
it started,
it's bladder is a little bit weak I guess when you get them spayed or neutered
that that can be a side effect,
which it never was.
And I took her out in the morning and I gave her a bath cause I knew I wasn't
going to see her for a few days.
So you know,
wanting to have her up on the couch,
you know,
watching the Hawks fucking blues game.
Right.
That was the game plan.
What ends up happening,
you know,
I forgot I didn't take her out for,
I waited too long.
She ended up fucking tinkling on the goddamn couch.
And then I had to take a route and then my wife is just like,
you know,
we're not going to see each other for a couple of days.
So there goes the fucking hockey game,
right?
One of the great ones of the year,
black cocks go up five to two in the first period,
scored five fucking goals in the first period.
And you would think the blues,
all that shit for them.
Thanks for playing.
Go get yourself some deep dish,
right?
All of a sudden it's five to three,
Five to four,
I think after two.
And then they tie it up.
Five,
five and then an overtime.
Vladimir data's Tech Goals scored the game winner.
Um,
I actually,
all I did was watch the highlights.
Um,
just fucking,
just,
it just seemed like a fucking dog.
That's one of those games like a basketball fan could enjoy like a true hockey
purist would be like,
you know,
there was no goaltending.
There was no d or whatever the fuck they would start fucking whining about.
You know,
like those kinds of people in baseball that enjoy a pitcher's duel?
I don't mind a pitcher's duel if they just mowing people down and they keeping
it moving,
but if they're grabbing than nuts and tugging on their fucking shoulders,
you know,
and it's taking nine fucking hours basically.
If it doesn't happen in October or in April,
I don't give a shit.
Like,
uh,
I'm really country towards baseball.
I don't know what happened.
I used to be that guy that could watch a game in May,
June,
July,
and August.
I'm just not anymore.
It's got to be April.
Like,
oh the summer's coming.
Take me out to the ball game,
take me out to that crowd.
Pay In full park.
And they've blocked off all the streets.
So they own everything and they can compete with the Yankees.
And then I,
I liked it to get an October.
That's basically it.
Oh,
by the way,
respect to the fucking Kansas City royal fence.
You just see how many fucking people showed up.
Jesus Christ.
I mean,
granted,
they hadn't won it 30 years.
So,
you know,
there's a bunch,
you realize,
think about that 30 years,
how quick that fucking goes by 30 fucking years goes by.
That means if they want it when you were like fucking 18,
how was I was 17 the last time they want it.
You're thinking how they want it.
You know,
they came close to 1980.
They fucking,
you know,
did great and 76,
77,
78.
This is what it's going to be like.
And then it,
they just drop off the fucking table.
And next thing you know,
you're 47 years old going,
oh yeah,
I remember when they won that in high school.
It was,
I like 2030 years ago,
one of those deals,
you just feel like you're fucking 9,000 years old.
Um,
but anyways,
yeah,
a bunch of people showed up.
I mean,
that looked like that rivaled the red sox won when,
uh,
when they broke the curse.
And that was only 30 years.
So a great baseball fans,
as you knew they would be,
were incredible football fence.
So,
um,
and I don't know why dude,
I actually kind of became a fucking mets fan,
which goes against everything.
You know,
I'm supposed to,
you know,
hate every team from fucking New York.
But,
uh,
Mike Price,
one of the cocreators F is for family from the Simpsons,
a sweetheart of a guy.
He's just such a fucking sweetheart.
I just wanted him to be happy
and I said he's not happy.
I wanted them to see a championship because he was watching.
Remember last year when we started writing the show,
like they,
they met,
swore in a good physician and they just started tanking and he,
and he had seen,
he had like,
you know,
I was like,
how did they do last night?
He goes,
they lost.
And he laughed.
I go,
Oh man,
that's,
I'm sorry,
Yoga.
You're gonna Watch them again tonight.
And he laughed and he goes,
yeah.
He goes,
we'll probably blow it again.
Like,
that's,
that's a real fan,
you know what I mean?
Like,
um,
when forsee was given,
was talking shit about,
I'm not shit,
he was just talking to me going to,
do you see how few mets fans were left last night when Casey clinched it?
That's a disgrace and blah,
blah blah blah blah.
And it's like,
it really isn't.
That's actually the norm because when your team sucks,
your stadium is half full.
All right?
When they get good it's full.
And then when they start to suck again and they start losing its,
it looks like they're definitely going to lose like half the stadium empties
out.
So really every team only has enough fans to fill up true fans to fill up half
the stadium.
All right.
All those extra seats are for when they're good.
Does that make sense?
Especially the ones down around home plate,
the ones that you see on TV,
cause those are all hookups.
You know what I mean?
Have you ever walked up to the gate to buy baseball tickets?
And they're like,
yeah,
hey,
can I,
yeah.
Can I get two tickets for,
uh,
for the fucking whatever.
Whoever the fuck they playing for the pirates or whatever,
what do you got available?
Then they got like two right behind home plate.
Never happens.
Those are Illuminati tickets,
right?
Those are the people who work at like Nabisco,
right in blue.
Some guy from Nestle,
you know,
and gave money to Hillary Clinton is something that,
those are the people,
the kids,
the kids are those people that suck.
Some of the register.
Their kids get to sit down there.
Right.
And they don't appreciate it.
You know,
they show up in their fucking Ferrari,
they got an eight ball and they're fucking shirt pocket.
The second eight oh three stiff down by three runs,
they're out of there.
They're already craving to do another bump.
You know,
either that or you're fucking,
you like a hundred years old and you got your bottom way,
way,
way back in the day.
But even then,
once they'd fucking build a new stadium,
they end up squeezing out.
Right?
And when it comes out,
the local newspaper write some article about Joe Sixpack an hour.
Now he's at the top of the stadium and the fucking ownership goes,
well,
they're going to look into that at this day and age in order to maintain a
competitive table.
But we have to look at the lake,
look at our phone,
right?
And then the whole story goes away.
And then those,
those,
those people up there that Bruce Springsteen and John Cougar Mellencamp boy he's
singing about,
right.
Then Al Gore talks about when he talks about,
I tilled the land I held,
I held,
held that tobacco between my fingers.
I don't know why he sounds like George Bush probably because I'm limited when it
comes to a impersonations.
Right?
Okay.
Those people,
they're all up there.
right.
People that work for 11 people is still tell racist jokes,
you know,
at an inappropriate time.
Those people,
the backbone of this country,
you know,
the silent majority
anyway,
fuck,
I'm talking about.
Yeah.
So my dog woke me up like three,
four times last night and I remember thinking like,
wow,
this must be like what?
It's like to have a new born baby.
And I thought about it for a second.
I was just like,
wow,
parents are still pussies because this isn't that bad.
You know?
As much as she got me up four times last night,
I'm deliberately just tea in the suffering.
Four toes.
Uhhh,
Troy for Toby.
I hate parents.
You know,
I fucking hate him.
Okay.
I is there anything worse than watching two people make a conscious fucking
decision to change their life and then whine about it or one of fucking metal
for the rest of that God damn life.
All right.
You weren't diagnosed with the child.
There's no tragedy here.
Yeah.
You decided to have one or maybe it didn't,
but you knew how they were made so that your own fucking recklessness.
You got a fucking kid quit your fucking whining and just cause you got a fucking
kid doesn't mean everything on TV has to turn into two fucking muppets throwing
a beach ball around.
All right.
People who are adults who don't have kids should still be allowed to watch
quality entertainment.
Alright,
how fucking hard is it to not have your kid watch that shit?
Especially when they're really young.
You can't just walk up and turn on the TV like you could as a toddler walking
up,
sucking your thumb.
You know,
coming in,
dragging your blankie and you're fucking wearing your diaper.
He just come walking up.
He just reached up.
Stand on your tippy toes.
Right?
And turn the fucking thing on.
Nine the remote,
all of those fucking buttons.
All you do is you just don't show the little maniac how to turn it on.
And then even if he knows how to turn it on,
you just keep the remote on top of the fridge.
Right.
Okay.
And you show him where you put it too.
Is there,
maybe I'll try to climb up.
He falls down.
He hits his big head,
right.
Gets his first concussion.
Break them in.
You know,
like the way they used to break in a new car.
People used to think,
you go out there and you drive like a hundred fucking miles an hour.
That was the way to break an engine to evidently it wasn't.
No,
it deadly.
Toddlers fallen off a stool trying to get a remote control off the top of
refrigerator.
Banging their little soft heads isn't a good thing either.
It's not bad if a kid gets a concussion,
it's just sucks.
If they go bald later on in life,
could you see that flat side of their head?
You know what I mean?
I don't want to talking about,
um,
I had a great,
a great time being backyard,
unbelievably fucking tired by the way.
And uh,
I had a benefit to do,
uh,
Rhonda is kiss,
which is a great benefit that raises money for people who are diagnosed with
cancer yet do not have the money to,
um,
to afford treatment because we don't have nationwide healthcare in this country
for whatever fucking reason.
It's the dumbest thing I've ever seen.
You know what I mean?
I love people who are against it.
It's like,
I so want to have nationwide health care because at least I'll get something for
my tax dollars.
I don't understand what it,
what are they doing with all the fucking money other than overpaying the
constant,
put them in the office to go build a fucking bridge.
Ah.
So anyways,
um,
and this was put together by,
uh,
by Dave Cushner who's doing the music for a fourF is for family.
And Him and his wife Christine put the thing together and,
uh,
was I going to say the,
you know,
he's,
former guitarist of velvet revolver.
So there was all these fucking rock stars.
Arie asked me to come down and,
uh,
open the show and then of course he said,
hey,
do you want to play a song?
And that's my rule.
I won't force my hobby on anybody,
but if you ask me to play,
I will play.
You have been warned.
So,
um,
we ended up playing a whole lot of love and I somehow was able to fake my way
through it.
And I got to play with a duff mckagan.
I swear to God.
Gilby Clarke and Cassia and then it was me.
It's fucking awesome.
And um,
what was funny was,
you know,
I kept bugging Dave going,
Dave,
what song am I going to play?
What song am I going to play?
You know,
and he's so busy putting together the fucking event,
him and his wife are that,
uh,
you know,
he didn't get back to me until like three days before.
And he goes,
you want to play a whole lot of love?
And I typed back,
no,
no.
Too difficult.
And then I just said,
I fucking stop being a pussy.
So I write yes.
And he goes,
all right,
cool.
So,
uh,
the event was Tuesday night and Monday.
You know,
I came back basically Sunday after two weeks of fucking drinking and having not
played drums in forever.
And also being a standup comic who really isn't even that good of a tremor.
And I went into the,
uh,
we went into rehearsal and I probably played the worst I've played in its,
he was even bad for a comedian who sorta plays,
I was fucking up to fill that,
um,
entered the song.
You know,
those don't dump.
But that a dad,
a dad,
God to go,
I was fucking that up.
And uh,
and I was just,
um,
I go,
dude,
it was fucking,
it was horrific.
It was fucking horrific.
I mean,
they would totally cool helping me a longer everything.
But,
uh,
the night before the Gig,
I couldn't sleep.
I was just laying there in bed going,
I'm going to fuck this up.
And I remember,
uh,
Gilby said,
hey,
just,
just make sure tomorrow that totally cool and supportive.
He just goes to it.
Just make sure tomorrow when you come out,
he goes,
just really hit him,
hit him,
don't tickle them,
hit him.
And I'm thinking,
Oh God,
this guy thinks I hit like a bitch.
He thinks I'm a little girl.
And I just sold the day of the fucking Gig.
When we were in Carson,
there was no singer.
And I,
uh,
that was messing me up even more aside from the fact that I suck.
Right.
So,
um,
I ended up,
uh,
I went on,
I went online and I just looked up whole lot of love,
no drums,
and someone had just like,
you know,
put together this track where it wasn't Robert Plant's singing.
So it's different phrasing than Robert did.
So all of it was enough to be a little bit different.
And I just played to that like a thousand fucking times.
And,
uh,
we went down and did the Gig and I somehow pulled it off.
And,
uh,
you know,
I,
I don't think I fucked up too bad.
I didn't see anybody trashing me on the,
uh,
on the Internet,
but a
duff was nice enough to walk over and stare at me during the,
that,
those dunk.
Dot.
And he was just going,
one,
two,
three,
four,
one,
two,
three,
four.
Literally had to hold my hand through that.
And,
uh,
it was fucking great.
It went,
it went great.
And,
uh,
I still can't believe it.
I still can't believe I got to do that shit.
And,
um,
and it was the,
one of the sickest fucking lineups.
I mean,
it was,
everybody was there,
man.
It was like a Dave Navarro,
duff mckagan,
Gilby Clarke,
Steve Stevens,
Billy Morris.
And Billy idol came out like his whole band came out with Josh Freese on drums.
I got to watch him the whole fucking night.
And then Billy Gibbons showed up out of fucking nowhere.
I swear to God,
it was like a rock and roll hall of fame night.
Mark Mcgrath was hosting the thing was fucking killing me.
He was,
that guy is so fucking funny.
He was standing there and he was given everybody the intros and making everybody
laugh,
you know,
as he was bringing out the bands.
And at one point he just pointed out to nobody in the crowd and he just goes,
what did you say,
sir?
Did you just say,
hey mark,
why don't you sing a song?
A number one hit that you wrote in 1997.
Is that what you just said?
Well,
absolutely.
And then he goes into that.
I just want to fly.
He was fucking hilarious.
So,
um,
I'm sure I'm leaving some people out.
Uh,
oh,
Juliette Lewis fucking murdered it.
Fucking murdered.
It sank dirty deeds.
Um,
and accreted song,
it was fucking insane.
That's all I got to say.
We should,
it was absolutely fucking insane.
Um,
and uh,
I got to slip in there for like five seconds
and I just remember after I watched like the first,
you know,
five or six songs go down in my jaws on the fucking ground.
Like I was literally like a,
I think I was speaking in falsetto like,
no,
you should have put me on first.
Um,
but whatever.
I survived it and it was a,
it was awesome.
So,
uh,
oh,
but I didn't tell you about my,
the set I had,
I did walk out and do,
um,
I had to do stand up like I had,
they wanted me to do a half hour and like,
do you need to open for bands?
Man,
that shit.
Nine Times out of 10,
that goes sideways.
It's like you show up this fuck everybody's standing up.
People that talking and you know,
they,
they had to see music and that type of shit.
So what I learned at that event is you just,
you just sort of play to the pit the first four to 10 rows,
he just played to them and then you just start going,
you know,
all people in the back,
if he,
if he could talk a little louder,
that would be great.
He just throw those in some self deprecating shit I probably shouldn't ended
with go fuck yourself at a benefit.
You know,
looking back,
I wish I didn't say that,
but uh,
other than that it was a,
uh,
an amazing night.
So I want to thank everybody that Ron is kiss for having me on that thing.
I will obviously obviously do that.
I would have done in any ways if I could just do standup on it,
forget about letting me sit in and all that type of stuff.
It was just a fucking incredible night.
Um,
I had fucked up to right before the show is starving and I won.
I walked down the street,
it was down,
it was at the El Rey theater,
so it was on a wheelchair and I walked down.
And La is not a,
a walkable city,
so I'm just walking down the street and it's just like,
all right,
I hop five guys burgers and fries,
which by the way is so fucking overrated.
It's ridiculous.
But they're stupid bags of potatoes laying around like,
Ooh,
look how healthy it is,
right.
You know,
and the fucking,
uh,
I ended up going to a chipotle.
I,
Ugh,
what a mistake.
I get three fucking tacos over.
I was really just walking down the street going,
all right,
what,
what am I going to poison myself with?
There was some Japanese place who was all and no barbecue.
So I was joking like,
oh,
no bar.
Oh no barbecue.
We don't automate this.
Right.
I was just like,
I'm not fucking eating there.
Right.
So I,
uh,
ended up going with chipotle lay and then that's not,
that's not good.
That's not good.
That's not a good look.
You don't want to shove three fucking tacos down you fucking pie hole before you
do a half hours of stand up.
You know,
and you know what's funny about Chipo lays how fucking guilty they are.
I don't know what the fuck happened to them,
but I came walking in there and they had a giant,
I was talking to somebody with the show about this at a giant sign that just
said food with integrity and they show all these natural in all this,
all this beautiful looking food and the food with integrity with the fuck.
Does that even mean?
Yeah.
What did he get busted for something.
It didn't drop a dime on it on it's other food,
friends to fuck food with integrity.
Then it was just a picture of a bunch of food,
healthy food.
I don't recall anything else up there.
And then next to everything up there,
it had how much calories it was tacos three,
anywhere from three 80 to 600 Burrito,
anywhere from fucking this up to fucking a thousand or 1500.
And I was just looking,
I was looking at the menu going like,
dude,
this is like a fucking sex offender that has to announce that he's in the
neighborhood.
The fact that they have to give out this much information about how much
Catholic,
what kind of shit is in this food.
And then they got that stoop food with integrity.
There was like the food version of a member,
that Obama poster when he was running,
it was all those different colors.
He was just sort of looking up and it didn't say anything like what,
what,
what?
I don't understand what that means.
Um,
it worked out right?
Eight years,
man.
Got eight years.
Um,
so anyways,
you know what I did miss as I thought I had my recorder set to uh,
record the Bruins for the season this year.
And for some reason,
um,
it's weird.
It's like I went on the road and all of a sudden it stopped working.
It's almost as if my wife was recording too many reality shows and when she had
to make a decision,
she shut off the Bruins thing.
Now I could never get her to admit that,
you know,
I,
but come on,
you know,
she does that shit to me.
I'm telling you.
And you know why I know she does that shit to me cause I do it to her if I'm
taking,
if I'm taping too fucking football games and uh,
like,
you know,
keeping up with the cons is coming up to stop me from tape and things like I'm
shutting that thing off.
I'm shutting it off.
I don't give a fuck right
now.
Um,
so anyways,
so I thought my fucking recorder was going to record the Bruins stars.
You know Tyler Sagan,
Jamie,
Ben,
Jason Spencer,
right.
I that Spencer was at the second line center.
Tyler Sagan has Jamie been on one side.
Jason spits on and others on the other side and the fucking motherfucker comes
back.
It comes back and scores of fucking hat trick against this.
I've even seen a highlight of it yet,
but uh,
I'm happy for him.
I don't know what happened to him with us.
There was a whole bunch or the usual rumors that they tell the fan base,
you know,
whenever,
uh,
whenever they get rid of somebody they always say,
oh he was partying too much.
Oh he banged the owner's daughter,
he fucked one of the other players wives.
It's always the same three fucking,
you know,
the same three fucking rumors.
I don't know what happened.
I have no idea what happened.
But um,
whatever,
you know,
there was rumors going like,
oh,
we showed up like fucking three games in a row wearing the same clothes,
you know,
cause he's out partying.
And I was just thinking like,
you know,
I think I did that at his age when I wasn't playing for a professional hockey
team.
I think that's part of being 20,
19 and 20.
Right.
Um,
so anyways,
so we traded him and like I predicted that was going to be a wake up or my
prediction was he that he's just going to take what they're saying is true.
He is either going to tail spin out and then write a book about being a complete
fucking [inaudible] or he's going to fucking whatever he was doing wrong.
He's going to fucking,
you know,
this can be a swift kicked in his ass and he's going to start fucking,
buckle and down,
which is what he seemed to do and it just instantly second he got over there,
all of a sudden he's fucking scoring goals.
God dammit.
I said that the other day.
The,
I think the Blackhawks are the only guys,
Blackhawks have a bunch of guys that they had to get rid of for salary cap
reasons or whatever.
They,
I think they might have the most guys around the league that they got rid of
that are either a,
they're on the first or second line of every fucking team out there.
It seems like it says like a form of black cock on like fucking like seven or
eight different teams out there.
Uh,
even the stars,
Patrick Sharp,
who was on their first line is now in the second line.
Right.
A daily face off.
Who's been watched?
Who's been looking,
I fucking love daily face off.
Anytime that Bruins have a game and my wife hasn't shut off the fucking
recorder,
I could actually watch it all you do,
you just go to daily face off.
You Click on the fucking team that you play in.
And do they have them all lined up there?
First Line,
Second Holloway does fourth.
All the defense spends,
they got all the jerseys,
all the numbers.
I know I'm geeking out about this shit,
but I would have loved to have had this as a kid.
Oh.
And I was a kid.
You had to buy a hockey cards.
He had a mirror rise him do it for years.
And then second,
you got to memorize so many retired.
It's already Auscare man.
Um,
so anyways.
All right.
What time is it?
Eight oh three.
I gotta I gotta jump off here.
I gotta jump off a little bit early here.
Uh,
about four minutes short.
Let me read a little bit of advertising here.
Uh,
cause I gotta get my ass to the fucking airport cause I'm going back to Philly.
I got a show to do and cheese steaks to eat.
All right?
Not stock calm everybody.
All right.
This is an important message for all the nut mantras in my audience.
Why did,
why are they trying so hard to be funny on these?
Why buy small nuts at the grocery store,
uh,
when you can get big beautiful nuts from nuts.com there is an incredible website
that I have to tell you about.
I'm contractually obligated to tell you about this.
Once I tell you the name of it,
you'll find it hard to forget.
nuts.com,
that's dot com.
It's as simple and convenient way to have nutritious,
delicious,
healthy nuts and so many other tasty treats from around the world delivered
straight to your door.
Right now,
new customers can get four samples,
choose from over 50 options.
That's a $15 value.
When you go to nuts stock.
Why don't you just fucking buy these at the grocery store?
Let me get to seem like they're fucking jewelry.
You know,
diamonds taken out of a fucking mine in Africa.
The peanuts,
click on the microphone and enter my Code Bur bur since 1929 this family owned
business has prided themselves.
Oh yeah,
we go,
ah,
this is why I said yes.
The old man.
These are the mom and pop nuts.
Everybody now like those evil corporate,
once you get down at the fucking grocery store,
since 1929,
this family owned business has prided themselves on delivering the best in nuts
and dried fruit.
You'll find anywhere you can buy the buy by the case or by the pound certified
organic certified gluten free.
Here we go.
With or without salt,
raw sugar free.
Hundred percent satisfaction guaranteed.
All right,
well they should have said that upfront.
Um,
I maybe I could have been professional,
not shit on him,
right.
Who knows.
We're going to go to the replay booth.
Uh,
choose from over 3000 healthy snacks,
including dried fruit,
sweet treats,
chocolate covered nuts,
every flavor of gummy bear,
monkey,
munch cookie and baking goods.
Uh,
almond flour,
Chia seeds,
monkey much sounds like a fucking insult from the 80 [inaudible] right.
Hey fucking monkey much get all the air
that's in the family of numb nuts,
right?
Chia seeds,
spices,
grains,
any powder you want to throw in your smoothie.
Oh,
all right.
All right.
My fault.
I striked the fucking grocery store from my comments.
Sugar and gluten free items in the,
uh,
the best selection,
tons to choose from coffees and teas,
over 39 different kinds of fucking coffee and over 170 flavors.
Gives tens basket buckets and nuts,
not startcom,
big salty,
sweet,
whatever kind of nuts you like to munch on and let them take care of you and
your taste bud.
Right now,
new customers get for free samples.
Choose from over 50 options.
That's a $15 value when you go to nuts.com and enter my code,
Burr B,
u,
r.
R.
That's nuts.com that's dot com.
All right,
one more boll and branch ball and branch B,
o l l and branch.
You probably spend more time with your bedsheets than any thing else you own.
You really shouldn't skimp on your bedding,
you know,
but most people do because great sheets of very expensive thanks to boll and
branch,
that's not the case anymore.
Boll and branch a two brothers.
And when you spend the big bucks on sheets with a super high thread count,
you think you're getting the best value.
But what you're really getting is to marketing Mumbo jumbo.
Thread counts have nothing to do with quality and don't get me started on so
called Egyptian cotton.
That's just the name of a plant grown in Pakistan.
In China,
you value your sleep,
but whenever you,
you had to a department store,
you're forced to pay a huge a markup for sheets that aren't even that great.
Jesus Damn fucking blowing the lid off the sheet industry,
aren't they?
Boll and branch sheets are different.
First of all,
you can only get them@bollandbranch.com so you know you're paying for quality
sheets and not for overhead.
I don't know anything about you yet other than you shitting on every other buddy
that everybody else had makes shakes and see what you're doing.
He hit Boll and branch talking a lot of trash.
Yeah,
I mean won a game yet and quite frankly,
they're the most comfortable sheets in the world.
Oh,
here we go.
They make,
they're made with entirely organic cotton and a night sleeping on boll and
branch sheets.
Make your makes your day so much better.
Which it made my reading better.
Three US presidents sleeps on Boll and branch.
Well,
Shit.
Who's left?
One of the bushes.
Jim Economy Bill Clin.
I bet he does.
If he banged some fucking broad right,
did our soil,
those comfortable seats shakes it off.
Anyways,
three US presently bump boll and branch.
These are people who can afford to sleep on any brands of sheets in the world
and they choose boll and branch.
They really can't afford to.
They don't get paid a lot.
The only made four grand a fucking year,
didn't they?
Oh,
that's right.
Afterwards.
Then they go around giving speeches for $1 million a whack that and they watched
the bribe money.
Then they get the nice sheets.
They even cut out all the middlemen department stores markups,
which by the way are up to 800% so you're getting amazingly luxurious seats for
a couple hundred bucks.
Boll and branch is so convenient.
You'll love the sheikhs.
What come on.
They'll boll and branch is so confident you'll love their sheets that they'll
let you try them completely risk free for 30 nights
and they don't want,
if you don't like him,
you give him back.
Uh,
it gets even better if you order right now that give you $50 off a set us free,
a set of sheets plus free shipping.
Just go to boll and branch.com and use the Promo Code Bird.
That's right.
Get $50 off a set of the meat.
What sheets said immediately by going to be o l L N B r a n c h.com and using
the Promo code [inaudible].
Well there might've been one of my worst reads of all time.
Look at that.
I'm over a half hour.
I still did a half hour.
All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Just checking.
Uh,
you guys have a great weekend.
You can
cars.
And,
uh,
before we get too far into this,
I do want,
I do want to hype,
uh,
what we,
what you got going on here.
You have a brand new show called on showtime called Dave's old porn,
which debuted about a week ago.
I'm no bill weeks ago.
Let's see,
we're about three weeks in and a and it's been going great.
It's yes,
for a premium cable,
it's a hit and a lot of people who,
uh,
are into retro porn cause it's mostly about the Harry seventies,
early eighties porn of yesteryear before Twitter.
I've said this a million times,
but before the web and all that kind of stuff,
you know,
old VCR top loading,
you know what I mean?
Just to let the listeners at home data just to,
to,
uh,
paint a picture for them.
What exactly,
yeah,
tell us about the show without spoiling basically.
Well a,
it's kind of the mystery science theater of porn where I bring out comics like
this week,
this Thursday at 1130 on showtime.
Bill burr himself will be there and we will be sampling,
jumping from clip to clip through Nina Hartley,
who is a public,
one of the greatest living legends of porn.
Nina Hartley Delight.
Super Cool Lady.
And we watch your clips.
Did you have fun watching her stuff?
Yeah,
I was,
I was absolutely a star struck that she showed up.
Yeah.
Didn't believe it.
I sat on a couch is me,
Nina and Dave watching,
uh,
and literally watching old porn and sitting there commenting on it.
And uh,
I thought she was cool as hell.
I was really,
uh,
like definitely,
I don't know how to like just she,
I don't know,
porn stars,
they just don't judge anything when you've just gone through all of that stuff,
they'd done,
they just kind of like,
hey,
you know,
whatever.
It,
I freaked out at one point.
You had a,
you had given away.
No,
I'm not just,
we'll be posting a little bit of that
please.
[inaudible] dot com
what I realized is that like,
um,
first of all watching porn with women is different than watching porn with too.
It's like,
you know,
sausage fest,
Bachelor Party,
you know,
let's watch a couple of stag films,
get drunk.
Everyone with their legs crossed trying to get hard on your younger.
Right,
exactly.
We brought some of the funniest ladies,
two ladies,
uh,
Whitney Cummings,
Chelsea handler,
Margaret Cho,
and uh,
it's cool watching it with a woman because they'd get the woman's perspective on
sex and porn and on the whole thing and they like it,
but they don't like it.
Like we like it,
you know.
Right.
That actually,
yeah,
that immediately was fascinating to me.
What,
what did you find was different?
Well,
uh,
they definitely do not like double penetration,
anal tonky punch,
anything that you,
any kind of,
any kind of just,
you know,
uh,
which were called facials and money shots.
All that stuff is really not in their bucket list stuff.
Ah,
I hope one day to do this with my
charmed.
It all depends on,
I think for most women that is like that.
But then every once in a while you'll meet a real thoroughbred and they'll
actually be,
will be relating to it the way you do.
Um,
it's hard to tie it.
Actually,
I actually saw I was messing around with this girl a long time ago and I want
one watch,
one of those Max hardcores.
Yes.
I love that guy.
And they were at,
I remember saying to her like,
uh,
yeah,
you're not going to want my point.
I'm watching at this point is really twisted.
You don't want to watch this shit.
And she says like,
now I got put on,
I put it on at,
and she was actually,
uh,
I actually got self conscious.
I shut it off.
And I was like,
I can't watch this with you now.
And then she was just like,
what?
She,
you know,
she,
what did she say?
She said she wanted it is the way she said it,
which was just the classic accused line.
And uh,
I had a lot of fun with that girl diff.
Oh,
good for her.
I really don't,
you know,
I really did.
You're an honest,
unassuming type.
So I never even thought you like porn cause I think cause some of it I,
I don't think he really understood what we were doing.
But then I think once you got into it you really like,
you know,
dug in.
And I liked that because at first we were watching this movie that Nina made
with Tracy Adams,
who is another legend of porn called the ultimate lover with Eric headboards and
it's kind of a Frankenstein ask film and we try and jump through the whole film.
It was really difficult,
wasn't it?
To Watch an entire movie.
Yeah.
I mean like you never do that in real life.
Watch a whole porn from beginning to end.
You just go right to the point.
Yeah,
exactly.
Or fast forward or whatever.
You know,
the phone rings or your boss walks in,
it's okay.
You know?
Well you know what it was about.
I got this way.
I think it's,
it's the being raised Catholic thing as crass as I am on,
on this podcast,
all the shit that I say in some of the stuff I talk about on stage,
you know,
I curse a lot,
but I do stay away from sex for some reason.
I can say cunt on stage,
I can do all that type of trash,
women misogynistic stuff if arguably I don't think so.
I like to think I have a point,
but uh,
but for some reason when I,
if I talk about sex on stage,
I'm always really self conscious and I feel like I'm being crass.
Uh,
I don't,
I don't know why and it,
and I'm not judging someone who talks about sex is just personally I think it
has to do with that,
that,
that sort of upbringing.
So probably the episode I did with you though,
that was the initial,
you know,
going out,
God,
I'm talking about this,
this is on TV cause I had no idea what the show was.
Um,
I was all how hardcore you were going to do it or the way you guys were going to
edit around stuff,
which I saw a clip,
which is fucking genius by the way.
It's really funny.
And um,
we've floated on the couch,
hey bill,
three weeks in.
They know,
I'm sorry.
I'm like Lucas,
I don't want to give away secrets.
George Lucas,
we're working with an actual comedian and a human being and not having me
digitally put it in.
Oh yeah,
exactly.
Well let me tell you something.
It rocked out cause we had the,
we had great comics like you and Jim Norton and Adam Carolla and has Norton's
aired yet?
No,
not yet.
But Norton to porn is like,
he's the soccer Julia.
He could find a threeway.
He could find a threeway at a church picnic.
I mean he is the best.
I mean he really liked gets into it.
We have these great closeups of him,
but I can see for yourself it's a little better.
Analysts on ESPN except for,
and that's why I want to watch,
that's why I was asking when is Jim's like,
I got to,
Jim's is coming out.
He's towards the end of the run,
but right now,
last week show for those who did watch,
and I think your crowd kinda would dig this,
like the people listening to his podcast,
his pocket,
Dave's old porn,
well known,
uh,
was uh,
the young porn stars,
Bella,
Donna,
Christina Rose,
Bobbi Starr,
watching the old retro Harry Porn.
And you'll never believe this bill.
But,
uh,
they found the quaint.
They were like,
look at this.
This is adorable.
The hair,
they didn't really dig,
but they like hair a little bit,
but,
but the sex,
they were like,
look how adorable.
They're cuddling and kissing.
They don't do that in today's porn.
It's really like,
like you said it in the show,
I'm not gonna give it away,
but it's like a workout.
It's like,
like a p nine zero x video.
It's like fucking hardcore and extreme.
So,
um,
am I talking too much?
No,
no,
not at all.
But I possible on a podcast to talk too much.
Not at all.
Okay.
But you got to give me credit being 15 minutes in and I've yet to go.
So Dave,
what is the inspiration for your cereal?
Did you always want him?
What,
what were some of the jobs you had before?
I don't think we've said this.
She had Thursday 1130 on showtime.
Dave's old porn,
the new hit show.
All right,
well it's a hit.
It's doing really well.
It's right after a Gigolos,
which is about a couple of male escorts,
right?
There you go.
It's the late night block.
And then the Twitter account is at old porn.
And these,
the,
the letter o and porn is actually not the letter.
Oh,
it's,
it's the,
it's zero number zero.
Cause that's Twitter.
But let me tell you this bill,
if they go to the Dave's all porn.com website,
they'll be able to see pictures and clips of upcoming shows.
Your share will be this Thursday and other stuff that we,
uh,
have a shot.
So,
but um,
it,
it's really,
uh,
it's when you say like,
how did I come up with the idea?
It's like I've been working on this idea for like four years.
I think I've told this to you like three or four times.
Drunkenly whatever.
Yes.
Sober this like a year ago.
Yeah.
I shot some,
yeah,
we shot this last summer and it took so long to edit cause it's all about
postproduction you saw and uh,
but besides that,
like I've been working on it for years and years and uh,
I came up with the idea it was co by a Stuart B.
I don't use his last name cause he is in television,
but Stuart Bailey and uh,
he,
uh,
he's helped,
you know,
helped me shape and guide it.
And like a showtime is the best place for it cause you know,
we're allowed to show everything up to penetration.
So everything isn't that crane.
Yeah.
And I thought when I was in,
there's always,
the one guy was like,
where's the penetration?
It's like,
I'm with you dude.
I'm totally went to sky.
It's like,
I feel like I cannot save this man.
You know?
It's like,
I know you got to you.
You're like,
I love porn,
so what time of day,
but what you're doing is you're kind of doing it the way they do movie trailers
right now.
When they show a movie trailer,
they show the entire movie except for the,
the basically the conclusion of the third act.
They show you right up until how the hero salts and I think that that's what
you're doing with porn because it gets,
if you actually showed the penetration,
then there's no point.
You want people to laugh.
You don't want people rubbing one out.
Is there watching?
I like a,
I'd like a little of both.
I'd like people to go like,
you know,
that was funny and now I'm hard.
What do I do?
You know,
like that kind of a thing and the dog runs out of the room,
you know?
Is this how you pitched the show when you came in?
[inaudible]
all right,
what else do we got?
We got dilemmas.
He a day.
Would you like to try it?
Dilemma.
Let's write a dilemma,
a dilemma.
Let's see if we can ancient align metal,
like have a,
you know,
a man stands on one foot and now this,
this is more just,
this is sophomore.
Okay.
Hey,
you fucking horse pill.
You don't even,
uh,
is this the first time you're seeing this stuff?
Oh yeah.
I don't spray shit.
I don't read.
I just totally wing it.
All right.
Uh,
let me,
it was a really brutal one here.
All right.
We'll give this to you.
Dave.
Would you rather eat a tablespoon of Kim Kardashians shit or suck and entire
fart directly out of Rosie O'donnell,
sucking directly on her,
uh,
obese balloon?
Not.
Wow.
You know,
it's such when you want to do both.
Well,
I don't know.
I would say that I would go.
Hm.
I Dunno.
That's a definitely coin toss if he asks me.
Cause I mean,
if anybody's shit's going to taste good,
you got to think,
I mean,
she's so printed proper.
You know what I mean?
I think she,
she gets some sort of ass pedicure,
I would think.
Like,
okay.
Yeah.
Once a week or something.
We hold is insured by something in way to London,
but ah,
no,
she's super hot.
So everybody would go with her.
But you know what,
I'm going to take her to the other direction.
Go with the rosy,
whatever the hell you said.
Oh look at that left turn.
And I'll even take it a step further because to show you how much I really have
no self esteem,
I would eat Susan Boyle's box if it granted wishes.
And even everybody goes,
what if one of the wishes was you never remember eating or box.
It's like,
I don't even give a shit.
I'm sure it's as sweet as her beautiful voice
bill.
Bill,
in your hypothetical world noises,
she would make hot wash the noises she would make.
Can you imagine?
I think she would pass up the sweet.
That'd be great to get there on of those,
those uh,
children's novel,
pasty thighs,
it's really like,
she has like fairy tale legs,
I would think.
You know what I mean?
Cheers.
Angel forts.
She's the,
she just queefs Angel Freres
I gotta tell you,
I think I would go,
I would go with Rosie O'donnell.
I would do that.
At the end of the day,
it's air.
It's just,
it just doesn't seem as bad.
I'm going to go,
I'm going to get so hot though.
I'm going to get science.
Yeah,
but you're not really experiencing her.
She just gonna Shit on a plate.
Like basically how you got to see her do it.
She doesn't like,
like an assistant brings that ain't right.
You get serious.
She's very busy.
She's,
she's out.
But she's,
she's done.
She's dodging the,
uh,
everyone who was outraged that her sham of a marriage was a sham of a marriage.
But you know,
I don't understand brill.
Who felt,
who felt they got fucked in that one.
Who Do you feel bad for?
The poor people at People magazine that have $1 million to pay for those dumb
photos.
I honestly could not give a shit about any of that bullshit or whatever,
but I'm just going to say this right now.
Don't you think just from just living in America of like pumping gas and like,
uh,
you know,
using the cash machine that like you've,
you've liked somehow over,
over your entire life,
just the contact of like people of other people touching shit that you've eaten
a shit.
Oh absolutely.
Yeah.
I think that like if you add collectively,
collectively it's like a probably like a nice big turn.
I mean you get your stomach pumped when he went to heaven.
Like they show you like this is how much shit you've actually eating.
You know,
like cock gives you a hotel.
Like how much change you've given to homeless people I guess at the chart here,
you know,
I had somebody in,
in Saint Louis did that,
you know,
you shake hands afterwards and you always have like that,
that,
that the hand sanitizer afterwards.
And I actually had an audience member denied a shake my hand,
he goes,
I'm not to cause of everything.
And I was just like,
yeah,
you know,
that's actually that.
Totally.
I totally understand why you wouldn't want to at this point.
And that always makes sure I,
I,
if I'm going to scratch my face,
it's always with my left hand.
Like I totally get why,
you know,
why we Mandela is probably the most famous for it doesn't want to shake hands.
And if you,
and people thought it was weird,
but if you're really honest with yourself and you think about the last 24 hours,
some of the things that you've done to yourself and you may be,
we're in a hurry.
He didn't quite clean up,
you know,
but think about it this way.
I've been to third world and like they can all have to real about it.
Yeah.
And they can only dream of like a,
you know,
like wet wipes and pure hell and shit like that.
I mean,
you know,
they're,
they're filthy all the time and they love it and they always have big smile,
you know,
like,
Hey,
what's up?
Don't they like shit on the side of the road.
Sometimes my squat and the one fountain that's in their country because some of
that,
yeah,
I've actually seen that they have like the people's bud day,
the people's good day.
Is that a new show?
That sounds like a new show on a new network.
We do it differently here at home.
All right,
advice bill and Dave will add that I need your help.
I dated this chick and a and I feel for,
I think I love her.
What's wrong was that I feel for you.
I think I love you.
I don't know Bobby Darin.
No,
no.
Come on man.
It was 80s.
I'm going to keep singing so you know it,
uh,
feel free to say about any song white snake.
I think I love what fucking jaws going to kill me all day.
All right.
Uh,
well anyways,
he said what split us apart is that she didn't like porn and I promised her I
wouldn't watch it.
Uh,
she had self esteem problems and like an idiot,
I broke it.
I guess he broke her self esteem.
I was just kind of a dick.
I tried fixing it and for a while things went back to how they were,
but she wanted a,
she wanted a break.
I agreed,
but later she started to like another guy.
I didn't like that and tried to get back with her.
We had sex and things were going great.
I thought everything would go back to the same,
but Lee it later,
she said,
we can't have sex.
After I felt depressed because I knew she didn't like me anymore and she started
liking this other guy.
When I was depressed,
I didn't talk to her much.
It lasted for three days.
This gift must be young.
It lasted for three days and during that time she started dating the guy,
brutal spelling errors.
So forgive my already bad reading out loud skills here.
This is almost,
we're about halfway through here.
If you want to start lighting a cigarette.
Uh,
I asked her why she went off and dated a guy she doesn't know.
She said,
because I was detaching myself.
I want to get over.
I want to get over,
but I'm having trouble.
Only time I am happiest when I listened to standup comedy and your podcasts.
Uh,
no.
He goes,
am smooching your ass there?
Um,
I feel bad for breaking her heart and because I feel like she didn't love me.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
This guy's,
he make it sense.
I was always there for her.
She had many problems when she was alone.
A stuck up for,
she got me.
I know.
I screwed up.
Oh,
this is like a sad note and what I can honestly see.
All right.
Anyways,
he's basically asking how can I get over her and move on?
Well,
what do you say,
Dave?
What is what I say your formulas,
porn will help you,
um,
in the immediate thing.
But uh,
in the long run,
yeah.
You gotta you gotta just a,
there's a whatever you've got to get out there.
I mean,
this kid,
he's still trying to,
I'm trying to like get this chick,
but she's already moved on because we all know one thing guys got porn,
but women can fuck any guy they want.
I mean,
honestly,
I mean like if you don't treat a woman right,
she will go out and like fuck your twin brother just to show you that.
Like you gotta,
you know,
whatever.
They're vicious.
They are be vicious or they can be amazingly cool.
So either way,
he,
uh,
you know,
he should just say like,
what,
chalk this one up for experience,
move on next chapter in my life and uh,
use the porn and the booze sparingly,
but keep it in the back pocket.
And there are chicks that like porn.
So maybe the next one won't have such a big problem about it,
but this girl,
it's called the dead end.
Move forward.
I have a,
I have,
one of my theories is when you break up with,
uh,
with,
someone is you get the fuck away from them.
Good idea if you can.
Yeah.
Because women got that.
They're just fucking geniuses.
They own it to just knowing,
right.
Where they could just sense like,
wait a minute,
he's getting over me,
and then they'll fucking call you up and just spin your shit around and then
just hang up and bi mission accomplished.
And they just do that until they're over you.
And then they just leave you in a puddle in the corner.
So my thing is you just,
you just fucking,
you break it off and that's it.
Exactly.
You're right.
Maybe this kid,
he,
uh,
works with this,
this chick where she lives in the room or something like that.
But you're right.
He's got to clear the decks,
move forward,
new experiences.
Like it's scary,
but you've got to just get out there and do shit,
but the poor and we'll help you honestly,
and it's corroding,
shopping,
such a,
such a press about the porn thing and uh,
you know,
it's amazing how she got over here at some point.
You're not going to marry this girl.
He can't watch.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Watch porn with that.
This isn't your wife emotionally dead as an old man here.
And let me tell you,
what did you look back and laugh at this?
[inaudible]
let's get into
some of the listener feedback for the week.
I got something from,
uh,
from,
from uh,
Germany.
It said,
hi billion.
I'm a,
a black Tunisian born and born and raised in Germany.
So I guess he's from Tunisia,
which I don't know where that is.
If I had to guess,
I would say Tunisia is right next to,
uh,
let's see.
We're not in Vietnam
and he was just laughing at me.
Um,
what the fuck,
what was that place when we were in Vietnam?
We weren't supposed to be in the other country next to it.
Like Laos or something.
Jesus.
Yeah.
Oh,
that cab driver.
What a Douche.
What did those right think the Maca.
Just so still with the geography.
Really.
You fucking Goddamn scientists driving a god damn cab.
Yeah.
Fuck him motherfucker.
Um,
so anyways,
after listening to your incredibly rule to t regarding last week's listener from
Hong Kong,
I decided to finally write you and show you that it ain't no thang for non
native speakers to talk the talk.
See,
I kind of went African American jive slang on that sentence.
Oh Jesus.
He goes,
it ain't no thang.
Maybe maybe he's trying to be funny or maybe he just saw an episode of a Sanford
and son.
I Dunno.
English is not that difficult to language to master.
Why are they such arrogant?
Because English is so simple to master your magic and just so stupid.
First of all,
you fucking moron.
If Germany was running shit like you'll want it to like your trash and me
yelling this shit here like you tried to for the last for two fucking world
wars.
Do you think I wouldn't have a problem master in Germany?
You fucking cunt.
All you fucking cunt over there who think you're so God damn brilliant because
you can speak English.
The reason why you're running,
you're speaking fucking English is because for a while there America was running
shit.
All right.
That's why you speak it.
Not because you fucking smarter.
You dumb cunts.
You just fucking stupid as I am.
I been over here.
I've seen,
yeah,
I watched your riding your bikes.
I see you're breathing with your mouths open.
Stop acting like just so fucking brilliant.
I'm not saying I'm better than you,
but you have this same cunt that I am.
Okay.
You just in a different situation,
go fuck yourself.
That's like if some white kid is born in Harlem,
right?
All of a sudden he knows how to dance and can pop luck because he's hanging out
with fucking African Americans.
Does that make any sense?
Well,
it does.
In my world.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I have had it with you fucking people from other countries talking down to me
like you're not just as dumb as I am.
All right.
I am on a whirlwind tour of fucking Europe right now.
I am traveling as an American and I got to tell you,
the architecture was brilliant,
but I gotta tell you I'm not exactly blown away by the intellect.
I'm not talking to people going,
wow,
this guy understands and can explain black holes.
You guys are doing the same shit that we're doing.
You're downloading music,
you're trying to get laid.
You want a sandwich when you're hungry,
go fuck yourself.
So anyway,
so he then goes on to say
English is just not that difficult a language to master a hell.
Everything else here in Germany is a cheap knock off of American lifestyle,
entertainment,
fashion,
music,
et cetera.
Uh,
you think we wouldn't somehow learned to talk American English?
Um,
oil,
excuse me for giving you a fucking compliment.
Okay.
You've Tunisian born Germany cunt.
All right.
From the Ukraine.
Hi Bill.
I just really want to let you know that how late,
you know,
how famous you are.
I'm living in a fucking Ukraine,
not even a capitol of Ukraine in a very small town,
more like a village.
And I'm listening to your podcast every Monday.
How cool is the Internet?
There's some guy in the Ukraine,
yet another place that I don't really quite know where it is once you get into
eastern Europe,
because when I was growing that was all fucking Russia.
Why isn't it once you got beyond Poland and Germany,
shit,
once you got to fucking East Germany,
it wasn't that Russia Ukraine.
Is that near Romania or is that a lettuce?
I'm sorry,
that was just a silly salad joke.
Um,
I'm living in the fucking Ukraine.
and I'm listening to your podcast every Monday.
Also,
I heard all of your podcasts since you started.
I was born here and never live in an English speaking country.
I learned a little bit of English in school and pick up the restaurant,
your TV shows.
See,
I gotta admit that fucking blows me away.
Yeah.
You just sit there and watch a TV show and you can pick up English.
Okay.
I want to talk to you like what of what English do you just like walk around
going,
hey,
up your noses with rubber hoses.
Oh,
Mr cat that does that.
What you do,
do you do just speak like American,
uh,
television characters whose given hill?
This is one of these things up.
Jealous of these people's abilities to pick up languages because I want to be
bilingual,
but I,
I don't,
I,
you know what it is.
I don't have to be,
you know what it's like,
it's like climbing up a rope.
Doesn't everybody want to be able to do that?
Just grab a rope and without using your fucking legs,
just go right up at like a James Bond who doesn't want to be able to do that.
But the thing is is to get through life.
You don't have to be able to do that.
So most people never,
never pick up.
That sort of strength.
Language is the same thing.
If I don't have to learn how to speak it,
I mean to sit there and actually just sit down and give yourself a fucking
homework assignment.
I don't know.
I'm failing miserably and my Spanish
and uh,
oh,
go fuck yourself.
You know what you got?
You know what you guys,
when this is like a game,
your special teams are better than ours in the lane.
Which department?
[inaudible].